I had a dream it was the end of the
world
everybody awesome news you may have
heard that they just cast Beast Boy on
the Titans TV show meaning that we know
who all of the Titans are going to be at
least for the first season I'm expecting
the roster will change depending on how
many seasons it runs you know between 5
& 7 years but the other really cool
thing is that we learned what their
production schedule is which gives us an
idea for when it's going to premiere so
I'll explain all that stuff and there's
a new round of the Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll announce a new winner at
the end of this we've already gotten our
first teaser from behind the scenes as
the Starfire actress is getting scanned
into the computer so that they can do
the special effects and she'll look like
she does in the comics what I'm guessing
is is that her powers will work a lot
like firestorms powers where she can
walk around without them activated like
a normal person would walk around but
when she loses her and starts
giving off energy it'll be like the
transition from firestorm standing
around to actually giving off bolts of
fire
[Applause]
but here's a rundown of the full cast
then I'll explain the schedule and when
episodes might drop I've already done a
couple videos about the other actors the
reason one that they just added is bees
boy so he rounds out their entire cast
its bees boy
Nightwing Raven Starfire and then Hawk
and Dove and there are other characters
too but they're relatively minor like in
the way that flash arrow the other DC TV
shows have the main teams but there's a
lot of other characters on the shows as
well Beast Boy is going to be Ryan
Potter you may remember him from big
hero 6 or something else the actor was
actually campaigning to become the Tim
Drake on the TV show but I think this is
just as good and they haven't fully
explained what they're gonna do with
Batman family on the TV show because you
can't do Nightwing without Batman so by
association they're gonna have to do
some bad family stuff and they just
named drop Bruce Wayne on arrow they
could have put Bruce Wayne's head on
that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham to
hang out in Star City recently no now if
I was running around the city during the
day and managing it as mayor while
running around at night frightening
criminals as a vigilante that really
would make me a superhero so we now have
four different versions of Bruce Wayne
Batman on the TV shows there's the young
one on Gotham there's the one that's
going to be part of the Titans TV show
whichever earth that they set that on in
the multiverse there's the new one that
we learned about in the arrow and flash
world of Earth one and then on
supergirls earth 38 there's also a
version of Bruce Wayne Batman so we can
talk about that down the road the whole
idea with Nightwing though is that he's
post Robin he's just come back to
blüdhaven he stopped being the main
version of Robin and he's trying to
strike out on his own so he hasn't
become Nightwing yet that'll probably
happen over the course of season one as
the Titans come together so like in
Episode one they all meet up for the
first time in the team slowly forms over
the course of the season as the
mysteries unfold whatever serialized
elements they're gonna introduce they've
already teased some of the characters
backstories so of course there's the
Trigon Ravens storylines that they can
do
there's Corey's backstory she's on the
run from her sister Blackfyre so they
have all that stuff happening too and
then you have all the regular stuff
that's happening on the earth so you
have
straight up magic you have aliens and
then you have the crime drama element so
if you're not a big comic book person
and you do want to read some Nightwing
stories to get you ready for Titans
based on what they're setting up he's
going to be a cop during the day and
then he'll be doing all this vigilante
Nightwing stuff at night that's Chuck
Dixon era Nightwing so it's volume 2 but
you can actually just pick up with issue
number 48 that's the very first issue
where he becomes a police detective in
Bludhaven he gets a partner that partner
is a character on the show so you can
read any version of Nightwing that you
want to but just based on the time
period that the show is set in volume 2
issue 48 would be the place to start so
there's a lot of cop stories in
Bludhaven but the comic book is just
Nightwing stories because this is a
Titans TV show they'll also do a lot of
Teen Titans stories because the big
difference between Teen Titans and
Titans is really just the characters
that were originally the Teen Titans
getting so old that they wanted to
introduce younger characters or like
okay we need some new Teen Titans so
that little kids will enjoy the comic
book but we don't want to get rid of the
older characters so the older characters
basically just spun off formed a new
team and called it Titans instead of
Teen Titans because they weren't
teenagers anymore so the TV show is
doing sort of a mixture of that where
they could do the classic Teen Titans
stories like they're really seminal ones
but some of the characters are a little
bit older they're like Oliver Queen
Barry Allen age so mid to late 20s so
the Beast Boy and Raven characters will
be a little bit younger Raven is the
baby of the group she's gonna be around
13 14 years old
Beast Boy as you can see as a teenager
pretty much everybody else is gonna be
mid to late 20s so once they start
shooting episodes and they start
releasing pictures of the cast they
start teasing stuff we can talk a little
bit more about what they'll actually
look like on screen but these are just
pictures of the actors from before they
started shooting so it won't look
exactly like this but the really
important stuff I know you all want to
know when our episode is gonna drop how
many episodes so what's happening is is
they start shooting the first episode
November 14th they don't finish shooting
the season until May 11th I know that
seems like a long time but there's three
different things they could choose to do
you may have seen the Star Trek TV show
that just premiered on the digital CBS
streaming service there
doing the same thing with Titans DC
Comics and Warner Brothers is rolling
out their own digital streaming service
its core like their version of Netflix
they could choose to roll out episodes
the same way that CBS is doing with Star
Trek discovery where it's one episode
per week and they start dropping them
before they're finished shooting the
season so if they decide to do that they
could actually premiere the TV show in
the spring of next year like sometime in
March April May but what they might do
is choose to wait to all the episodes
are done and roll it out during the
summer or during the fall of next year
because the big thing that they haven't
done yet is announced when they're gonna
launch the streaming service how much is
gonna cost whether it will cost money or
it's gonna be ad supported or even
release a teaser for that matter so what
I'm expecting is is that because they'll
be shooting episodes they might release
a teaser for this digital streaming
service later this year before the end
of the year just to get you hyped up
like hey this is coming next year we're
gonna have these TV shows Young Justice
season 3 will be the other show that
drops on the streaming service so I
think the idea is is when you get your
first episode of titans you'll also get
your first episode of Young Justice
season 3 but there's gonna be I think 23
or 26 episodes of Young Justice they'll
only be 13 episodes of Titans
so Titans is a live-action Young Justice
of course is animated the week that I'm
posting this video the middle of October
is still about a month away from them
starting to shoot so I'm not expecting
any teasers or pictures of the
characters or the costumes or anything
like that till the middle late November
maybe December but I know everybody's
asking is this going to be connected to
arrow flash the other TV shows what
about Gotham they have a version of
Batman on that TV show but because it's
on Fox I think it's kind of spinning off
in its own little universe the thing
that they've said about Titans is that
because they want to do it a little bit
differently than the CW shows it sounds
like it won't be connected in season 1
or it'll be like black lightning where
it's done by Greg Berlanti the person
who's doing all the other CW shows but
instead of saying that it's connected
it's not connected they just don't say
anything until they make up their mind
in future seasons because they're
shooting Titans in black lightning in
different cities from the other TV shows
logistically it's just a nightmare
across those shows over in plus the DC
streaming service that Titans will
premiere on has nothing to do with the
CW network they're two completely
different entities so if your friend
asks you if Titans is going to be
connected to flash and arrow just say
they haven't decided yet that's the best
answer that we can give right now so I
think that just confirms that the Batman
of the Titans universe is going to be a
different version of Batman that we just
learned about on arrow and the flash
otherwise everything seems like it's
going great Geoff Johns is working on
most of the episodes personally in a way
that he hasn't with the other DC shows
so what will happen is is I have some
new Rick and Morty that I'll try to post
if I have time later tonight but my
non-spoilery thor ragnarok review will
post Thursday morning then I'll post my
arrow video and I'll explain what's
going on with Batman on flash and arrow
like they named drop him that mean he
exists it gets a little more complicated
after that congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Luke Skywalker the
second please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to rewatch
that Batman flash trailer and you can
click here for my flash episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight